[Music]
there is something new to record
every day about the national customs
history
geography and products of western
countries
the source books that i am using
although written only seven or eight
years ago
and in some cases 15 or 16 years ago are
concerned with matters dating
no later than 50 or 60 years ago
they are thus lacking in contemporary
information
for which we must await the appearance
of newer books
[Music]
in a certain work america is said to
mean new world in some european tongue
according to one opinion america was
discovered by a subject of the king
of portugal called americus from whom
the name was derived
according to another opinion this land
was first discovered by a man of genoa
italy named columbus hence this land
should be called colombia
the inhabitants are of several races and
customs differ according to locality
but they all make no distinction of
class literally between noble and mean
in the southern part of that land the
people live by tilling the soil
in the north the people manufacture
diverse sorts of things
some of them carry on trade in all
directions going most frequently to
europe to the east
and west indies and to china it is said
although this country is merely a part
of america
it is so large an area its people are so
numerous
and its vigor is so pronounced that it
is commonly referred to simply as
north america it was formerly just a
vast wilderness without even having a
name
about the year 1683 englishmen
colonised carolina in the southern part
of this land
then in the year 1734 they sent several
hundred thousand colonists
to new york and connecticut it is said
some years later several tens of
thousands of englishmen
who refused to subscribe to the tenets
of the anglican church were arrested
and sent to this distant country these
people lacked sufficient food and
clothing at that time
but they privately rejoiced because
there were no rulers in this land
a number of years later their
descendants came to number over
300 000 and the products of the land
became extremely bountiful
[Music]
during our horeki period england wasn't
war for some
years the people became sorely enfeebled
and the loss in foreign trade was not at
all inconsiderable
the english sought therefore to employ
the people of this land america
and use them for their own ends
the people of this land however resented
their abusive language and
scorned their cheap wages and refused to
obey their orders
they even seized and threw into the sea
some
342 boxes of tea that had been brought
from india by the english
in great wrath the english dispatched a
number of warships
and blockaded the most important port of
this land
the people found themselves in most
desperate
straits and officials of the 13 states
assembled
to ponder the situation a military
official named
washington and a civil official named
franklin
promptly stood up and declared we must
not
lose this heaven-given opportunity we
must
several relations with the english
forever
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so quick update from coco who's been
good enough to learn japanese to help
translate some sources for the channel
[Music]
luckily mine and coco's recommendation
this week doesn't require her newly
acquired polyglotism
as it is in english and is about the
pilgrims who traveled to the americas
all that time ago a fantastic look into
the experience of traveling on the
mayflower
and a great counterpoint to the japanese
perspective presented in this video
magellan is always a great choice if you
want more context for our videos
it's basically a very bingeable netflix
for documentaries
it has the widest range of history
content available anywhere
among lots of other genres click on the
link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
george washington died on december the
14th
1800 he was a north american burger
a term applied to prison folk living in
towns and
combining the three professions of war
agriculture
and commerce who became a general
that age produced many heroes of whom he
was the greatest
he was born in fairfax virginia one of
the republican
states in the year 1734.
his father was a big farmer in this town
his grandfather was a man of england who
60 years previously had fled
civil war in his native land and had
come to this country
to live as a child he observed the rules
of his family
he entered a school at williamsburg the
name of a place
that place was formerly the capital of
virginia he was by nature
wise and progressed rapidly in his
studies becoming particularly well
versed in mathematics
after a time he left the city school and
returned to his homestead
where he worked at farming in his spare
moments he studied battle tactics
in the year 1752 france built a
fort in ohio the name of a place in
north america
and england becoming angry attacked it
but no decisive result was obtained
an english governor-general who had come
to virginia now ordered washington to
negotiate peace terms
with the french general this was not
accomplished but he ascertained in great
detail
the exact situation of the enemy
the english general made washington a
major and ordered him to proceed to
ohio at the head of 800 troops from
virginia with his few troops he fought
bravely
against the strong foe an english
official named braddock
arrived in virginia with troops in the
year 1755
and washington joined his forces as the
leader of a detachment
with the rank of adjutant an officer who
supervises everything in a military camp
washington commanded a band of troops
whose duty it was
to loot enemy provisions and his
spirited fighting greatly enhanced his
fame
and caused all his associates to respect
him
in the year 1759 washington resigned
from his command
he married a woman of high birth and
returned to his homestead
there he devoted himself to his regular
calling
as a burger he studied most sedulously
events occurred in the year 1776 that
caused the colonists in north america to
hate
their mother country england and
washington voluntarily
used his wealth to equip troops
on april the 19th 1778 at the battle of
lexington the name of a place his side
suffered many casualties
on may the 10th that year a meeting was
held in philadelphia
the name of a place and troops were
raised in the various states
washington was chosen commander-in-chief
by common acclaim
and he devoted himself to affairs of
state in this time of
national difficulty military supplies
were not ample
and troops had been acting as they
pleased without obeying any rules
but he was extremely strict towards the
army
and impartial as opportunities arose he
led his troops in attacks on the enemy
and gradually saved the country from its
peril and established
peace and order but he undertook no
unorthodox
scheme nor did he hazard any project
that depended on good
for successful fruition
in the spring of that year 1778 an
english
general named howe was defeated by
washington
he fled from boston but with many troops
and administered severe defeats on
various armies
washington however being very cautious
left that place quickly
and was the only one to preserve his
army intact
[Music]
he adopted the good tactics of avoiding
a frontal clash with the enemy
preferring to wait for some favorable
opportunity
later his plans working out well he
crushed the
hessian troops at trenton and defeated
an english general
at princeton the aggressive power of the
american forces became greatly enhanced
bringing fear to the english and winning
renown throughout the world
in the year 1780 they captured an
english army
at saratoga france came to the
assistance of the americans
and final victory was achieved all this
was due to washington's great ability
the english now realized it was
impossible to win the submission of the
americans
and peace negotiations was started a
peace conference was held in
paris paris is the capital of france and
the conference was held there probably
because the french had helped the
americans
the home country finally became an
independent nation washington
now resigned from his command his
associates appreciating his great
services
and esteeming his virtue tried hard to
keep him from leaving
but he was adamant and returned to his
homestead in virginia
here he lived in quiet solitude
for a year or two
[Music]
peace had been secured but no system of
government had been established and
there was no
unanimity of public opinion owing to the
gravity of the situation
a general meeting was held in
philadelphia everyone asked that
washington became
high official hence unable to help it
he again looked after the affairs of
government he established institutions
and
issued laws which were so well designed
that they are still in force
today the next year
another assembly was convened and
washington was named
highest official saijokan for a term of
four years
when this term came to an end he was
asked to serve for yet another period of
four years
he was resourceful and conscientious in
his administration
in the country there was a person called
hamilton who was
wise eloquent and well-versed in
political matters
so he was chosen by washington to assist
the latter
in governing bury the name of a
westerner
says that when the republican government
was established in the country
the people were greatly exhausted but
that washington was in office for eight
years
and managed the affairs of state so well
that there was excellent
military preparedness the nation
prospered the people enjoyed peace
and the country's renown encompassed the
earth
this is quite true the nation's good
reputation was re-established
its trade was revived and a dilapidated
country
was reborn as a newly risen nation
the national debt was no longer regarded
as unpayable
every family prospered men worked
diligently production greatly increased
and the government's revenue grew
and grew the people were governed by law
and not by individuals their customs
were benevolent
and they behaved like persons of high
birth
[Music]
europeans all marveled at the excellence
of the governmental organization
bury sudetto commenting on him says
washington was
circumspect and discreet in managing
matters
so his achievements are not so well
known as hamilton's
in the realm of government washington's
name
will be established in history forever
yet in his day there were some people
who made slanderous charges against him
he was deeply hurt by this and when his
term had been fulfilled
in the year 1798 he returned with relief
to his homestead there he lived in
simplicity after the manner of the sages
apart
from the world washington died at the
age of 67.
there was none among the people of this
republican nation who did not mourn his
death
and even people of other lands showed
great sorrow
his name was therefore given to the
capital to perpetuate the memory of his
achievements
when about to die he prepared a will
freeing his slaves
giving a large sum of gold to the
government establishing a college in
colombia a place name differing from
colombia in south america
and founding a school for the poor in a
certain place
his mausoleum is in mount vernon his
villa
the people have not yet put up any
monument to this great man or even a
tombstone with an inscription recording
his achievements
his name however has an imperishable
place in history
obviating the necessity of a tombstone
nothing more could one ask
[Music]
washington had a dignified bearing he
was an able official and a manly burger
he was circumspect in his actions and
undaunted in the face of great
difficulties
his devotion to his country was
indomitable
his guiding principle was the
preservation of national honor
he cherished his country gave prosperity
to its people
and was ever ready to serve others he
always had a sound basis for his views
but never sought to force these views on
others in managing affairs he was strict
but
benign this was his heaven-endowed
nature
truly worthy of respect and adulation
he was an exceptional man born to do
great things
and to achieve success and distinction
you